[Musik]
in unserem heutigen video geht es um
globale hegemonialpolitik das heißt mit
welchen mitteln eine nation ihre
weltweite vorherrschaft auf und ausbauen
und passend dazu haben wir uns einen
neuen sponsor und euch ein nettes petit
grain ausgesucht bevor wir also in die
hegemonie hand politik der realen welt
einsteigen möchten euch ohne große
vorrede unseren neuen sponsor conflict
of nations vorstellen conflict of
nations world what really übernimmst du
die kontrolle über die streitkräfte
einer globalen führenden nationen und
die verantwortung für ihre militärische
expansion wirtschaftliche entwicklung
technologische forschung und
internationale diplomatie es handelt
sich um eine recht beliebtes
langzeitstrategie spiel das auf dem pc
im web browser oder auf dem handy
gespielt werden kann bei denen eine
mensch bis zu 100 spieler miteinander um
die globale vorherrschaft ringen darin
baust du nach und nach seine
infrastruktur und streitkräfte auf und
beginnt dann gegner zu bekämpfen und
direktorium zu beanspruchen mit den
anderen menschlichen spielern gegen die
online an triffst kannst du schicken und
auf diese art eine vielfältige
diplomatie entfalten das konzept der
langzeitstrategie von concessions
erzeugt dabei eine art bestechenden
realismus für das langfristige ringen um
die weltherrschaft das spiel erhält war
ein paar pay to win elemente ist
ansonsten jedoch free to play das heißt
du kannst du über den link in der
beschreibung oder diesem video einen
vollkommen kostenlosen account
einrichten und es da sowohl auf seinem
rechner als auch auf dem handy spielen
solange du möchtest und das beste wenn
du auf den link in der beschreibung
klicks erhältst du als bonus 13.000 gold
der ingame-währung und einem ganzen
monat premium abo gratis dazu dieses
angebot gilt nur für 30 tage also zögere
nicht zu lange und von am besten noch
heute damit an seine truppen zu
mobilisieren neue allianzen zu schmieden
und siegreiche schlachten zu planen wie
gesagt euch kostet es gar nicht und uns
helft ihr damit weitere informative
videos zu drehen also nichts wie los
probiert conflict of nations mal aus und
jetzt ab in die reale genial politik
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der russische krieg in der ukraine hat
die globale politische agenda auf den
kopf gestellt plötzlich sind die augen
der welt wieder auf europa gerichtet
russland die ukraine öl und gas sind
derzeit die heißen themen aber habt ihr
schon mal die redewendung gehört tu was
wichtig ist und lässt sich dabei nicht
von dringlichkeiten stören nun wir auch
nicht aber es scheint klar zu sein und
ist genau das was die usa unter
präsident joe biden machen wenn es um
die amerikanische dominanz in der asien
pazifik region geht
[Musik]
wie ihr als treue visual politik
zuschauer sicher bist hat der
amerikanische einfluss in asien
langfristig oberste priorität im weißen
haus und deswegen lassen sich die
amerikaner auch nicht so kabine kriegt
davon abhalten in asien aufs gaspedal zu
treten man könnte vielleicht sogar sagen
sie nutzen die gunst der stunde die usa
hoffen das unbehagen und die angst
auszunutzen die durch die russische
invasion entstanden sind es die angst
vor autokratischen regimes mit neo
imperialistischen gelüsten die china und
russland die dazu führt dass anderes
helm wieder der verbündete ist den jeder
haben möchte und ende mai 2022 mitten im
krieg in der ukraine und während das
pentagon immer mehr waffen an die
europäische front schickte besuchte us
präsident joe biden südkorea und japan
denn beide sind enge verbündete der
vereinigten staaten und sie waren in
letzter zeit das zweifelt ihre
beziehungen zu um es macht auf allen
ebenen zu stärken natürlich gefällt die
neue liebe zu den amis nicht jedem
beiden asien tour wurde mit einer
gemeinsamen flug show und einem
feuerwerk von den üblichen neidischen
nachbarn gestört
russische und chinesische jets
patroullieren während beiden besuch in
ostasien
nur stunden nach den beiden asien
verlassen hat startet nordkorea eine
mutmaßlich ballistische
interkontinentalrakete und zwei weitere
raketen tatsache ist dass die
vereinigten staaten seit jahren ein
bedeutendes netzwerk von allianzen in
der gesamten asiatisch-pazifischen
region fördern wir haben schon einige
videos darüber berichtet und wenn sich
die us-politik in den letzten jahren
nicht auf militärische beziehungen zu
asiatischen länder beschränkt hat will
die beiden administrationen nun auch
politisch und wirtschaftlich viel
stärker in asien aktiv werden
[Musik]
schon als vizepräsident unter obama war
bei den italienern regierung die das
trans pazifischen handelsabkommen tdp
vorantrieb die recker donald trump gab
es wieder auf weil er tvp für einen der
größten fehler der us außenpolitik hielt
das weiße haus prüfe aber nun wie ist
diese zusammenarbeit wieder aufnehmen
kann das alles dient einem ziel die usa
wollen nicht nur die dominante macht in
der asien pazifik region bleiben sondern
ihre dominanz noch weiter ausbauen und
zementieren und heute erklären wir euch
mit welchen drei strategien sie dies
anstreben die erste davon haben wir
bereits in früheren videos ausführlich
besprochen sie besteht darin den
chinesischen einfluss in asien
einzudämmen und zu zeigen dass die
vereinigten staaten immer noch der
wichtigste akteur in der region sind
selbst wenn dies bedeutet dass die usa
einen aggressiveren kurs in der taiwan
frage einschlagen müssen
beiden schwört taiwan zu verteidigen
dabei müsst ihr folgendes im hinterkopf
behalten auch wenn das weiße haus dazu
neigt die worte des präsidenten im
nachhinein zu relativieren es spielt
keine rolle denn beides wiederholte
behauptung dass die usa aktiv und
militärisch eingreifen würden um
teilbaren zu verteidigen ist kein zufall
sondern eine echte absichtsbekundung die
zweite große strategie besteht darin die
beziehungen zwischen zwei seiner engsten
verbündeten zu fördern nämlich südkorea
und japan mit anderen worten washington
möchte dass diese beiden länder ihre
beziehungen verbessern und ihre alten
diplomatischen konflikte ein für allemal
hinter sich lassen denn immerhin war
korea mal eine japanische kolonie was
oft schwierige beziehungen zur folge hat
ziel ist jedoch auf sich der amerikaner
dass beide länder eine starke
demokratische volk in der region
aufbauen
eine front deren stärke keineswegs zu
unterschätzen wäre wir reden bei
südkorea und japan schließt nicht über
zwei der reichsten und technologisch
fortschrittlichsten länder der welt zwei
staaten die zusammen ein bip von fast 7
billionen us-dollar und einem
militärhaushalt von derzeit 94
milliarden dollar pro jahr vorweisen
können der in folge der derzeitigen
weltweiten noch kräftig steigen wird
beide länder sind eines der stärksten
duos der welt zwei vorzügliche partner
für die usa und den start der gegenpol
zu china
die dritte große strategie beschenken
uns ist die förderung eines netzwerks
von allianzen um eine stärkere
militärische politische und
wirtschaftliche integration mit den
ländern der region zu erreichen während
seiner letzten reise gab beiden viele
hinweise darauf wie die neue
außenpolitik von angriffen in asien
aussehen wird und zwar alles mit dem
ziel hier in schach zu halten
ein treffen unter freunden
es mag vielleicht überraschend klingen
aber internationale beziehungen werden
sehr stark von den persönlichen
beziehungen der staatslenker
untereinander beeinflusst in den
internationalen beziehungen ist alle
politik persönlich denn letztlich
basiert alles auf vertrauen und
vertrauen entsteht nur durch persönliche
nicht freundschaftliche aber offene und
aufrichtige beziehungen zu seinem
gegenüber damit du dich nicht darüber
wundern muss welche absichten sie im
schilde führen und wenn man es so sieht
war der besuch für die usa ein voller
erfolg denn beiden und sein amtskollege
jungen haben sich anscheinend sehr gut
verstanden aber das hier ist natürlich
keine seifenoper bei visual politik geht
es hauptsächlich um die fakten wie zb
diese die vereinigten staaten haben am
23 2022 eine wirtschaftskooperation für
den asiatisch pazifischen raum ins leben
gerufen das sogenannte eindruck des
electronic framework mpf
südkorea und japan sind
gründungsmitglieder mit dem club sind
unter anderem auch australien indien und
indonesien
ok aber was hat es mit dem ipad auf sich
und warum in aller welt sollte was
schenken ein neues internationales forum
schaffen wenn man doch einfach dem
transpazifischen freihandelsabkommen cpp
beitreten könnte nun anders als das cpi
ist das ibf kein freihandelsabkommen das
auf die abschaffung von zöllen und
handelsschranken abzielt sein hauptziel
ist die wirtschaftliche integration der
insgesamt 14 gründungsmitglieder zu
fördern das heißt zum beispiel regeln
für freien handel untereinander zu
schaffen und die zusammenarbeit zu
fördern in bereichen wie technologie
digitale wirtschaft und saubere energie
und auch die korruption soll bekämpft
werden vor allem geht es bei diesem
forum aber darum die lieferketten
zwischen den mit island zu stärken und
robuster zu machen vor allem sollen
diese nicht mehr so abhängig von china
seien auf diese weise könnten die
mitglieder des id es einen
entscheidenden wettbewerbsvorteil
gegenüber jenen weltregionen erhalten
die noch immer blind auf china setzen
auch wenn die erheblichen risiken dort
nun offenbar geworden sind
das war sprechende über ein forum dessen
aufgabe noch nicht ganz klar zu sein
scheint aber offenbar strebt verschenken
danach dieses forum zu einer der
zentralen säulen seiner us außenpolitik
zu machen und diese sollte als
gegengewicht zu der von china
angeführten integrations bewegungen
fungieren wie etwa dem regionale
kompetenz ökonomik partnership cep
[Musik]
es gibt sogar spekulationen darüber dass
der us regierung über dem itf hinaus ein
neues viel umfassender das abkommen über
freihandel und wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit als ziel vor schwebt ein
abkommen dass zb die weitere entwicklung
und produktion von mikrochips fördert
denn der mangel an solchen high tech
komponenten hat in jüngster
vergangenheit die automobil technologie
und militär industrie auf der ganzen
welt stark beeinträchtigt darunter
natürlich auch die us industrie und
siehe da nur kurz nach beiden besuch in
südkorea und nach dem soul dem
us-beitrag wurden zwei wichtige
ankündigungen gemacht schaut euch an
[Musik]
südkoreas eske group kündigt 195
milliarden dollar investitionen in chips
batterien und biotechnologie bis 2026 am
samstag investiert 355 milliarden dollar
um seine führungsposition im chip und
bio sektor zu festigen
550 milliarden dollar
investitionsvolumen allein durch diese
zwei koreanischen riesen das muss man
sich mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen
um euch eine vorstellung zu geben über
welche dimension wir hier reden diese
zwei privaten investitionsprogramme
übertreffen dass die idee kompletter
reicher volkswirtschaften wie norwegen
oder israel quasi über nacht ist diese
branche in südkorea zur höchsten
nationalen priorität geworden ein zufall
wohl kaum
aber das ist noch nicht alles neben dem
fpf trafen beiden union auch wichtige
militärische vereinbarung wie zb die
aufstockung der us truppen die in der
region stationiert sind zudem will man
den umfang und die häufigkeit gemeinsame
militärmanöver erhöhen außerdem sagte
biden dass die usa zur verteidigung
südkoreas die volle bandbreite ihrer
militärischen fähigkeiten einsetzen
würden und das schließt also durch fest
auch tron war von einem reaktoren
gegenüber nordkorea wird also wesentlich
rauer 1 180 grad kehrtwende gegenüber
der politik des ehemaligen
südkoreanischen präsidenten und der aus
rücksicht gegenüber den nachbarn im
norden die zahl der militärmanöver
reduziert hat und es geht noch weiter es
gibt sogar spekulationen darüber dass
südkorea einseitig die militärischen
beschränkungen aufheben könnte auf die
dinge und der ehemalige präsident mundt
geeinigt hatten es handelt sich hierbei
um die drei neuen vereinbarung
[Musik]
was es damit auf sich hat nun führt
korea stationierte 2017 das
amerikanische raketenabwehrsystem
die dieses kürzel steht für terminal
high altitude area defense und soll
ballistische raketen abfangen peking war
von diesem system natürlich alles andere
als begeistert und reagierte mit harten
wirtschaftlichen repressalien diese
führten dazu dass sich unsere verkäufe
in china um zwei drittel einbrachen der
koreanische mischkonzern lotte group
sein geschäft in china einstellen musste
und chinesische touristen zeitweise
nicht mehr nachdem real reisen durfte
[Musik]
wir haben über diese diplomatische
konfrontation und die rüden methoden
pekings sogar ein eigenes video gedreht
das ich euch verlinken werde den
damaligen konflikt löste man mit den
eben erwähnten rhinow agreement im
rahmen dieses abkommens verpflichtete
sich südkorea erstens dass es keine
weiteren raketenabwehrsysteme im land
stationieren würde zweitens das so sich
keinen regionalen ob das system unter
führung der usa anschließen würde und
drittens das ist nicht teil des
militärbündnisses sein würde an dem
südkorea japan und die usa gleichzeitig
beteiligt sind doch diese vereinbarung
scheint nun hilfe recht zu sein zumal
das südkorea mit dem elvis system auch
ein eigenes raketenabwehrsystem
entwickelt und auch in japan dem anderen
großen verbündeten der usa tun sich
einige hoch interessante dinge was
beiden strategie der allianzen gegen
china in die hände spielt das land der
aufgehenden sonne hat sich dazu
verpflichtet seinen militärhaushalt zu
erhöhen und wir versuchen seine
beziehung zur schule zu verbessern er in
erster linie verstärkt japan sein
engagement gemeinsam mit den vereinigten
staaten und sogar deren engsten
verbündeten so hat japan mittlerweile
militärische abkommen mit australien und
den vereinigten königreich unterzeichnet
der us freundlicher und auch ausrüstungs
freudige premierminister vom yoshida
holte mit seiner regierungspartei bei
den jüngsten parlamentswahlen gar einen
großen sieg erringen damit kann er ohne
unterbrechung bis zu den für 2025
angesetzten wahlen regieren und die
langfristigen politischen ziele seiner
partei durchsetzen hierzu zählt vor
allem die stärkung der nationalen
sicherheit und das lang gehegte ziel die
pazifistische nachkriegsverfassung so zu
ändern dass japan eine starke und
proaktive militärmacht mit enger bindung
an die usa wird die bedeutung all diese
themen haben wir euch bereits in einem
separaten japan video ausführlich
erläutert nun dürfte also auch der hier
beschriebene kurs eine noch breitere
politische unterstützung erfahren und
geschieht könnte auch mit seiner
sicherheits und bundespolitik einen
echten durch matsch hinlegen und auf
diese weise schaffen die vereinigten
staaten eine koalition die schon alleine
in der lage ist china in schach zu
halten aber das ist noch lange nicht das
ende der fahnenstange an der das banner
der stars and stripes weg denn gute
beziehungen zu japan und südkorea sind
nicht das einzige us dass washington im
ärmel hat aufgepasst
[Musik]
eine asiatische nato
die usa sind gerade dabei eine ganze
reihe spezieller militärbündnisse zu
konsolidieren ich spreche hier
insbesondere von kurt den corporate
security dialogues zwischen den usa
japan indien und australien
dabei handelt es sich um ein eher
informelles bündnis das im vergleich zur
nato weit weniger klare strukturen
aufweist und auch keinen echten
beistandspakt mit bündnisfall klausel
darstellt aber sein potenzial zu einer
asiatischen nato heranzureifen ist
durchaus vorhanden was natürlich vor
allem in peking verbrannten horror sorgt
denn auch wenn gott geben die amerikaner
derzeit wirklich gas um nach der
russischen invasion der ukraine das
bündnis zwischen den usa japan indien
und australien zu festigen diese länder
sind kurz nach beides reise nach
südkorea in tokio zusammen gekommen und
haben dort einige neuentwicklungen auf
den weg gebracht so haben sich die
staats- und regierungschefs der quad
staaten darauf geeinigt eine große
maritime initiative zu starten die in
der pacific partnership vom maritim
domain eröffne die mda
die staats- und regierungschefs der vier
länder standen eine wichtige initiative
für bessere überwachung maritime
aktivitäten in the pacific und wofür
genau ist das alles gut nun man will
eine verstärkte echtzeit überwachung der
endo pazifischen mehrere durch die
mitgliedsländer ermöglichen
wir sprechen hier nicht nur über eine
militärische funktion diese initiative
wird es auch ermöglichen die bewegungen
der so genannten dark chips zu
kontrollieren also jener scheffel die
ohne ihre erkennungssysteme fahren
entweder illegal fischen oder verbotene
ware schmuggeln aber es geht noch weiter
die finanzierung der quad haben sich
auch auf die gründung der quad cyber
security partnership geeinigt
[Musik]
quad fordert gemeinsam ansatz zur
verbesserung der cyber-sicherheit die
quad länder riefen zu einem gemeinsamen
ansatz zur verbesserung der cyber
sicherheit auf und erklärten ihre
kapazitäten im rahmen des quad cyber
security praktische programm zu
koordinieren es ist dabei vollkommen
klar gegen welche gemeinsame betrug
dieses bildes gerichtet ist denn wenn es
um schutz vor cyberattacken geht hat man
ein land besonders im visier china das
immer wieder in verdacht steht seine
konkurrenten im internet zu attackieren
oder auszuspionieren natürlich gibt es
aber nicht nur gute nachrichten was die
umsetzung der amerikanischen strategie
angeht in denen hat sich geweigert
russlands überfall der ukraine scharf zu
verurteilen weil es befürchtet dass
putin dann die lieferung militärischer
ausrüstung stornieren könnte
[Musik]
allerdings beobachtet man in neu delhi
genau welche performance die russischen
waffen im realen konflikt hinlegen und
erkennt immer mehr dass ich bei der
gegenüberstellung mit westlichen
waffensystemen ein versprechen des
russischen rüstungsmarkt things nach dem
anderen in luft auflöst schließlich will
man im ernstfall nicht unerwartet im
artillerie regen stehen denn erst die
jüngst hat sich gezeigt dass die
milliardenteuren s400 luftabwehrsysteme
entgegen ihrer papier spezifikation eben
nicht in der lage sind heinz geschosse
abzufangen indien wäre also gut beraten
seine rüstung strategie generell
komplett neu auszurichten wenn es im
globalen wettbewerb der militärmächte
überhaupt noch mithalten will eine sorge
die man in australien nicht hat wurde
dort im rahmen des neuen autos
bündnisses doch die beschaffung einer
hochmodernen atom u boot flotte
beschlossen wir haben darüber sogar ein
separates video gedreht allerdings ist
dieses jahr in canberra die labour
partei an die macht gekommen und es kann
sein dass die neue regierung die
beziehungen zu china wieder verbessern
möchte hier geht es jedoch vor allem um
strafzölle auf australische waren die
auf die stimmung drücken in puncto
sicherheitspolitik pferd auch die
linksgerichtete regierung einen ganz
klaren wenn ich noch stringenteren kurs
der neue verteidigungsminister richard
morris hat nun gar einen wesentlich
engere zusammenarbeit zwischen
australien und den usa gefordert um das
zu vermeiden was er als katastrophales
scheitern der us australischen
abschreckungs doktrin indopazifik
bezeichnet während seiner rede in
washington argumentierte maus dass china
die größte militärische aufrüstung seit
dem ende des zweiten weltkriegs betreibe
welche als gewaltig ansieht sie
verändere seiner meinung nach sowohl die
strategischen gegebenheiten des
indopazifik als auch der gesamten welt
politik komplett mars warnte dass die
allianz zwischen australien und den usa
es sich nicht leisten können auf der
stelle zu treten und den status quo
hinzunehmen und fügte hinzu dass sie
sich in den kommenden jahren eine viel
schwierigeren strategischen umfeld
bewegen werde doch trotz dieser
herausforderungen ist klar die position
der usa im asiatisch-pazifischen raum
ist nicht nur so stark wie seit langem
nicht mehr sondern wird noch massiv
zunehmen während des kosten noch alles
darauf hindeutete dass china hier die
oberhand gewinnen würde hat das wieder
erstarkte international auftreten und
die multilaterale strategie der usa
alles verändert mit südkorea japan aus
strahlend und den aufständen allianzen
wieder quad und dem ende business
economics teamwork will die beiden
regierungen die position der usa als
number one player im asiatisch
pazifischen raum noch weiter ausbauen
natürlich ist das spiel noch lange nicht
vorbei weswegen die preisfrage nun
lautet da hatten beides pläne letztlich
ausgehen wird die us strategie
erfolgreich sein und wird ist washington
gelingen die macht den einfluss
russlands und chinas gleichzeitig zu
sprechen was könnte die usa jetzt noch
stoppen wie immer sind auf eure beiträge
und diskussionen zu diesem thema schon
sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat zwar gibt es mit
einem like das mit freunden vergesst
nicht dass auch mit glöckchen um keines
unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
vergesst bitte auch nicht dass zu diesem
video vortrefflich passende online spiel
unseres sponsors conflict of nations
auszuprobieren wenn du dich ließen zu
fühlen und über militärische strategien
spekulieren weil es solltest du es
unbedingt über den link in der
beschreibung unter diesem video an
spielen natürlich und dass auch jeder
zeit über eine spende von euch dieses
projekt weiterzuführen paypal in das und
findet in der beschreibung unter dem
video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]